c'est un chantier sur trois jours une
intervention suite à une chute
accidentelle d'un poteau en béton
le câble est quasiment au sol les
équipes d'aînés 10 me remettre les
infrastructures en place
éteindre à nouveau le câble électrique
basse tension dédiée aux particuliers
là on voit des chantiers qui se passent
en extérieur et en aérien à prier des
chantiers qui sont en sous terrain et
des chantiers qui sont dans d'autres
configurations donc le métier les
diverses et variées on a énormément de
travail sur le renouvellement du réseau
sur les chantiers liés à à la croissance
avec le grand paris beaucoup de
constructions d'immeubles neufs beaucoup
de modernisation certaines zones se voit
rencontrer les jeux olympiques
parmi les techniciens polyvalents sur ce
chantier julien barbé il a rejoint
récemment incitent yvelinois d'aînés
disent ça permet d'apprendre de
nouvelles choses est dans un grand
groupe qui donne des perspectives pour
pour une évolution de carrière avec des
métiers qui peuvent au fur et à mesure
du temps évoluer et prendre des
compétences et des responsabilités
c'est quelque chose qui est intéressant
dans son recrutement de techniciens et
les dix recherche des candidats allant
du cp au bac +5 électrotechnique
le salaire annuel est fixé à 24 milles
euros ce qu'on recherche principalement
ses des salariés qui ont un bon savoir
être qui ont envie de s'investir dans
des missions de service public qui ont
envie de servir nos clients et qui ont
un vrai une vraie envie d'intégrer
dans les yvelines 40 nouveaux
collaborateurs ont été recrutés en 2020
le groupe de gestion du réseau de
distribution électrique anticipe déjà
des besoins de recrutement pour 2021